[Music]
oh my gosh
stop it both of you oh why is he alive
why is he here
it's over jerry i'm calling in the boys
and guys
why do you have prida's drink have you
had it this entire time
give it to me now drop the ring
what do you want part jerry
you want to stay here
where did he go
[Music]
why do i see temporary employees
socializing on hotel property in the
middle of their shift
we were just terrance was celebrating
you know the uh hotel's most problems
taken care of oh yeah congratulations
teamwork is dreamwork right yeah it's
taken care of right tom
it is so taken care of right
tom what is he doing he's not doing
nothing
why are you acting nervous huh you're
actually nervous i'm not acting nervous
no what's in your pocket ah
nah oh turn wait no no he's what are you
doing
oh i'm so sorry
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
this is definitely your bed
tom and jerry are literally one of my
favorite cartoons it was important to
have the animated characters be in 2d
because the classic cartoons were in 2d
boom
we could actually have them look exactly
like they always did but at the same
time
live in a 3d world
they're still going to be somewhat 2d
which is really cool
we thought it was the best way to give
homage to what the cartoons have always
been
what i am proud and what i do physically
allows them to be able to animate even
more
i'm sorry he's a little animated
animation and
real people collide in a very exciting
way
this movie synthesizes these elements in
a cartoon that i grew up on and loved
there's a certain charm to tom and jerry
just make you smile
it's really decadent to watch it's a fun
[Music]
world
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous enemies
[Music]
tom and jerry are about to start over
cause that's what
friends are supposed to do
in the big city
[Music]
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings
and we're about to host the wedding of
the century do you think you're
qualified to take on this position i
shine under pressure like a diamond
or rihanna one other thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now i'll catch
oh wow this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory
[Applause]
[Music]
if a evolution of these mouse is tweeted
out to insta book face or
tiki talk we will be ruined no sir
that's not gonna happen
that rodent is toast
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat in a mouth
he's dying with us
i think i might have just pulled this
off the whole
bouncy
thing
[Music]
bye